la pac la politique agricole commune se
sentent 11 milliards d'euros versés
chaque année à la france et plus de 600
millions d'euros pour la seule région
centre val de loire
la quasi-totalité environ 570 millions
d'euros est constitué dette directe à la
surface exploitée mais aussi de mesures
agri environnementales
cette politique agricole commune
convient-elle à nos agriculteurs je vous
propose d'entendre deux tourangeaux
le président de la chambre d'agriculture
d'indre et loire et la secrétaire
national de la confédération paysanne à
gauche henry freinant agriculteurs
ensuite touraine sur 110 hectares de
grandes cultures blé colza orge
tournesol à droite tu emmanuelle girard
installé depuis une quinzaine d'années à
proximité immédiate de l'agglomération
tourangelle 65 hectares de terre
quelques bovins laitiers des chèvres et
une production de fromage et de yaourt
en vente directe la survie de leurs deux
exploitations dépend à des degrés divers
des subventions européennes
les primes pac ça représente à peu près
150 % de mon revenu j'ai plus de primes
pac le revenu que je dégage
bon c'est le cas typique des
exploitations céréalières du secteur
quand on est con céréales 15000 euros de
revenus 21 22 mille euros de prix de
pâques
ces subsides en tout cas cette
subvention aujourd'hui qui arrive dans
la trésorerie de la ferme c'est une aide
de trésorerie
quand elle arrive à temps bien sûr c'est
à peu près entre 35 et on approche
peut-être des 40% du but du chiffre
d'affaires en tout cas annuels de la
ferme
ce constat n'est pas nouveau car depuis
la création de la politique agricole
commune en 1962 la pac a toujours
consisté à rééquilibrer les coûts de
production européens par rapport à ceux
de la concurrence mondiale
un soutien toujours nécessaire même s'il
est régulièrement critiqué aujourd'hui
la difficulté c'est qu'elle soutient on
apporte aux céréaliers qui font des
protéines parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut
tourner les choses comme on
le soja qui arrivent d'amérique du sud
il arrive à deux fois moins cher que ce
qu'on est capable de produire de
protéines chez nous donc ça ça fait
partie des choix politiques où on peut
se dire est ce que il faut par ailleurs
orientées tout la pac vert
un plan protéines et un vrai plan
protéines mais ça veut dire qu'il faudra
y mettre de toutes façons beaucoup
d'argent ou interdire les importations
de soja d'amérique du sud
mais ça ça me paraît beaucoup plus
compliqué tant qu'on est sur une volonté
de vouloir exporter de la qualité et de
ne pas vouloir importer en tout cas en
masse des produits tels que la viande
aux hormones ou autres enfin je vais pas
tous les citer
je pense que la volonté politique elle
sera de toute façon l'essentiel sur l'
usage des subventions européennes et sur
l'avenir de la politique agricole
commune il n'y a pas toujours consensus
au sein des agriculteurs en revanche
tous ou presque sont d'accord sur un
point hors de l'europe point de salut
pour l'agriculture